робота уряду викликано не задави мною
вид ставки кабмін він і моїм сином сонця
поважають за kidney політики арсен
яценюк вдалося з барахти крісло
прем'єра alemannisch знайди з так там і
без 6у парламенті в нього за дружину травень
проти the wind чоловіка ліфті чи то
реформи на ховаєм українського ладу знову
марну і шанс на мої будні по передаєте
німецькі депутати в Росії дали
дестабілізувати україну шкода україни
сама доводить ситуацію до абсурду ми над
вечеря та спокій теща український репетує лікаря
і шанси поки що мої будні держави на
bespeco у тому ще й зможеш витрачає
обожнювання зроблю в цю україну через
проблеми з корупцією у даного кана не
закінчив ви побачилися за політичну
дах даний ви куна не вбити on кінеса
і президент Петро Порошенко поважають на
заході мін за яка прем'єрою петлю вигляд
ставку і при цьому травня ж половина його
фракції не голосую за віру уряду
європейці не розуміють такий поєдинок
українських політиків
отрути дали більше сумніваюсь а в тому що
цю систему можна подала ти з людьми
вчорашнього дня до річки люди з
політичну кар'єру та в Україні мають
натомість довгу історію перебування store
складі c означає проблем з 2
система переносить elnur на заході
кажуть українську політику як сир
цьому будинку і так ну і далекі рує
олігархічних груп їх play вам українці
потрібної переформатування малюків
уряду а ю сі ей про ваблю еліти в team
до їжі дасть рукавам вибори до європейських
політики
ставлю сяду жваво пану дасть руками
вибір і приносити Україні як раніше
адже молдові чотирьох до шести місяців
нестабільності на я хвалю от і муть вся
важливими рішеннями в тілі ось і мотив же
прийняти і за раз історично мити не
боротися за інтерес його крему та
політичні сили в коаліції а наріжте
у св дом від ще ви вирішується частка україни
я до такого виду ринку авансом збоку заходу
позбавлені будай призу грізну на лиж і
безвізовий режим
асоціації з'їзд а petrenko про конфлікт
з росією а і знову не україни як
держави європейські політики у якій
за кличуть київ з виглядом цієї серйозності
ситуації